let's watch this math mcconaughey video
i got to see this oh oh
giggles you want to watch giggles
giggles that's what we're calling them
after this
eagles mcconaughey yeah giggles are
great
oh i still can't smell his last name
but i need some long branch bro this
looks good i'm just watching the preview
right now and
and telegram oh oh my god bro branch
whiskey
i'm going to [ __ ] oh man i got a big
ass
suggestion for fool's gone wild what is
it matthew mcconaughey
what's that is like i don't get it waze
like what's up fool like
bro how have they never used this it's
[ __ ] it's begging for it in his last
name
matthew mcconaughey wait wait is that
him wait what's that picture of him
reading john grissom right there
click that oh i gotta open i'll [ __ ]
instagram no no no no no
no no no no
just open it and you tab okay so what's
this
is this is this a brand deal that he has
with john chris
let me put this on screen bro you have
got to be [ __ ] me
with this you have got to be [ __ ] me
with this
bro i love this guy man jake dragons is
back
no one else can do this picture
no one else
say that again jake bridges is back
a time for mercy by john grissom comes
out october 13th
oh yeah he's definitely trying to do bro
yeah
john grissom like slipped through some
cash hey bro
or do you think he's like you hitting
john grissom like he's like you know
he's like a soundcloud rapper like
trying to make it that like texas boys
like you you got to rt this before me
man
of course bro this is hard as nails
who's the last
person on instagram you saw with a book
brand deal
yeah seriously like and that got more
than a thousand likes
look at the first comment ryan mccarthy
nothing like a captivating read
in the book emoji what a dweeb
nothing like it captivating
i never snitch on you daddy oh jesus
that's another one i love john grissom
books
nobody gets a [ __ ] dude
this is crazy because like he's like a
permanent thirst trap like
anything he does is a thirst trap yeah
which is wild
you know he can't he can't even
everything he does
you know what here's my big big brain
thesis
essay right here what is it matthew
mcconaughey is the most objectified man
he's the most five man yeah
of this generation yeah you know what he
could probably
yeah i mean i'm i'm about to objectify
him further
but i'm just saying he could probably
ride a vespa with a helmet on
uh yeah and win and win that argument
yeah and
it well cause he wouldn't scream yeah he
just
he'd just be like he'd say some
confusing ass [ __ ] and then uh
yeah and then and then check his left
titty for sweat and then drive away
his left hit after saying it and then
drive away
he no he'd go he'd go green lie [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i feel like it has to be like more
ambiguous and he's like well you're
gonna
do whatever the world made you do
but i got a green light calling my name
so i'll see you later honey
she's like oh wait no let me leave my
husband
[Laughter]
bro on that h3 podcast they pulled up
um goddammit i forget the guy dan maybe
dan i forget that one of the
producers names yeah but he pulled up he
pulled
i guess he's been collecting matthew
mcconaughey quotes for a long time like
all the most absurd quotes nice
and he pulled up like eight of them to
get my reaction and some of them were
so absurd i mean i it's it's exactly
what i imagined his book to be
it's just entirely these they're like
these oxymorons like he'll write
something and it makes
no sense like it's a total contradiction
it's so [ __ ] great and funny
i mean and did he even have a writer for
that book like i want like i wonder if
it's just
solely him writing i feel like he he
wrote it
yeah and also that [ __ ] drops pretty
soon by the way oh
so keep that in mind because i did order
it so
oh you get a little little book club
reading oh yeah
let's get let's get let's get in with
giggles over here hold on
and also wait hold on before you open
that look at that top left one as well
that
looks like it might be a reaction video
our man's doing reacts
we have to watch that after our mans is
doing reacts hold on
yeah hold on hold on let's get giggles
over here
bro i can't wait for the for
you know our our matthew mcconaughey hey
uh subset
to comment oh man giggles is such a good
nickname
[Laughter]
and they're gonna go to this video and
be like hi giggles
and then you know the the male subset
would be like nothing like a good
chuckle man
the male subset yeah it could you know
we got we got dude mcconaughey stands
yeah we got to feel that respect that
respect
you know true life i'm 28 years old and
i run a stand account for matthew
mcconaughey
i'm a straight male but but still i
can't
i'm just a fan i can't i mean the guy
has charisma what can i say
i mean running a stand account for
mcconaughey is it's too easy
it writes itself i mean i literally just
re-upload the clips
with glitter on it and they do [ __ ]
numbers
these things pop the [ __ ] off dude
i'll get a little just this is the most
this is the strangest video i've seen
in a minute so what if oak and mesquite
were throwing a party at the lake house
this weekend
i'd go
wait is that it that's it that's the
whole thing
that's it i didn't even do that
what if oak and mesquite were throwing a
party at the lake house this weekend
i'd go
what is that
that's why he's such a great actor you
can't even laugh like that try to laugh
like that
it sounds like we sound like goats
bro how does he do what so what if oak
and mesquite were throwing a party at
the lake house this weekend
i'd go
the first lap reminds me of taylor
canips in that one video
[Laughter]
this is the best vine i've ever seen oh
my god
he literally can't do any ha ha that
laugh
love him ha ha that laugh oh my god that
laugh
and blown away well crafted what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
that laugh at the end though priceless
blown away by this four second video
i'm absolutely blown away by what you've
managed to accomplish here dude
in this one sentence the same person is
somewhere like
inception sucks i didn't get it
blown away by you matthew
let's let's keep our man's reacts dude
this guy's yeah yeah let's see this
is two guys bro 830 000 views
let's go wait he's going on a green
light book tour bro
let's pull up come on um he's starting
in october
wow so he's he doesn't give a [ __ ] no no
he's like he's getting out he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he's like no i'm
we're doing this am i supposed to smash
on the road oh
he's watching his audition tape yeah
hey man who's this
hey
[Laughter]
that's just how he laughs there it is
again that's just how he laughs
[Laughter]
wait okay wait hold on read this comment
on the right by being
being b this made my day
knew you had it the moment you were on
that screen 28 years ago and that movie
still holds up
just like you god damn god
dude that is [ __ ] brutal thirst
i can't wow yeah that's federal offense
online hornets
dude you've been praying for 28 years
holy [ __ ] that that's that's like that's
like being this like a fan of like a
like a sport like a
franchise in a sport that just never
wins like a cleveland browns yeah like
like one day
yeah it's gonna happen and it like
requires so much to
line up for that when they finally do it
i knew they had it
i knew it 28 years ago when i was four
and my daddy brought me to my first game
i knew it i knew it i saw some
in those jerseys that's the male
equivalent for for being a matthew
mcconaughey
thirst fan is just being a browns fan
yeah dedicated to losing
yeah holy [ __ ]
i love that he's not providing any
commentary no
he's literally just watching it and just
going
and he's thinking about i know he's just
like looking at
okay let's let's see let's see what he
has to say let's see yeah okay see
yeah cause this is what the [ __ ] we care
about
what's up this nice
look at that so
that audition which i've never seen
was my audition for wooderson days
confused
which i'm sitting there and i watched
and i go man that was 1992
28 years ago
you thought you might just have a little
three-day job for a summer hobby
and 28 years later i still got a little
summer job that turned into a career
hard flex hard flex
hard flex
somebody watches it's like oh my god
it's so hot you can do math
it's also you can tell that he he's like
he's trying to use his poetic like actor
language
oh yeah he kind of needs to write to do
that yeah
like he's trying to make a he's trying
to like make up you know a [ __ ] oomph
here he's trying to
go for it with a statement and he's like
and 20 look at this 28
28 years later i still got that summer
job that turned into a career and it's
like it doesn't
that doesn't really make sense yeah
yeah i mean
i think this is a tough ass flex damn
that was 28 years ago and who would have
thought
i would have turned out to be one of the
baddest [ __ ] on screen
that's what he should have said that's
what i'm saying that's what he [ __ ]
showed us at
damn this is 28 years ago and look at
that i've been in this [ __ ] 28 years
yeah not a single insurance commercial
[ __ ] and i thought it was a summer job
and that summer job
paid for this [ __ ] summer house look
at this
summer house yeah exactly look at this
wood
this wood finish behind me
oh yeah that's what i need to see toxic
mcconaughey
yeah [ __ ] yeah not this [ __ ]
subdued ass [ __ ] i want to see a
[ __ ]
i want to see him get [ __ ] up on his
own whiskey
[Laughter]
like i want to see him just house a
bottle a long branch
you